all right here we go again another bus i
believe five this past week uh emptying
out in uh new york's uh port authority
bus terminal one of the largest on the
planet i might point out uh these are
all those migrants from texas the
governor abbott is sent here mayor eric
adams furious about it here uh but the
texas governor's saying i want you to
experience what we've been experiencing
texas and and you deal with what we're
trying to deal with but many of those
migrants by the way are free to go where
they want after this now the first bus
you might recall many of them emptied
out at the milford plaza hotel famous
hotel in the early days the lullaby of
broadway you probably remember that or
those of a certain age i'm sad to admit
that
another that age that was then this is
it now uh actually they are given a slip
of paper a return court date but they
can go where they want
all of that worries john katkow of the
new york ranking homeland security
committee
member who is kind enough to join us now
congressman
i was startling hear just that part that
once they get off the bus and they're
given a date you know to return and and
adjudicate all of this
they can go where they want uh do we
know where they go is there any tracking
of them or where they go
no that's the problem neil and if they
are tracked or tracked temporarily
they're given a piece of paper and they
said within six months or a year you
gotta call into this number and check in
with us and the amount of people that
are actually checking in
is very low as you might imagine but
they're giving this piece of paper
because they're here illegally let's not
forget that and they're here because
they have asylum claims quote-unquote
asylum claims and then they have an
asylum hearing at some point down the
road the problem is the system is so
overwhelmed with asylum claims that the
backup is years and years and years so
these people get lost in the window and
they have no idea where they
are and a lot of these people are
working for the mexican cartels to work
off the debt they owe them for the
crossing because that you can't cross
from mexico into the u.s without paying
their cartels at least 10 grand and so
they're making billions of dollars a
month and these people owe them money so
in effect they're working to pay off the
debt to the cartels which is crazy so if
you can just educate me on the process
here congressman you you get through the
border uh let's say at texas or arizona
any one of these other states uh
you have to be processed
so they take you to some of these
facilities oftentimes they're detention
facilities of the rest but but many
other times in fact far more often i'm
told uh
to sites much further north and to
states and cities like new york et
cetera
then they're given that piece of paper
but does that mean then this controversy
earlier in the week where
federal officials had closed at opened a
gate that texas national guardsmen had
closed are inviting more of this by
keeping it open at certain entry points
so that these individuals indeed can be
processed in the united states and can
take a bus pretty much anywhere
yeah now there's no question about it
and you know you know what that video of
the texas national guard trying to
secure the border and the customs and
border patrol acting under the orders
from the president and administration
basically had to go open up that border
uh uh open up that gate and let them all
end because
gates like that all across the border i
don't know how many congressmen but the
national law says you got to keep them
open because that's an entry point now
if i'm
trying to get
entry to this country i'm i'm going to
go for those open gates aren't i
yeah well that wasn't an entry point
that was someone's private property um
so that's what so they gave the
government the right to close that gate
after texas national guardsmen or to
open it after the the guardsmen had
closed it
that's a darn good question has
something when we take over the house in
january we're going to figure out but
you can bet no matter what the cartels
took that video and are now advertising
on instagram and tick tock and uh all
these other mediums to get more people
to come across because they're making so
much money off that's the insanity of
what's going on at the southern border
and the overlay with that the one-year
anniversary of what happened in
afghanistan and the fact that we have
66 people in the terror watchlist seized
at the border this year alone which
stands the reason at least how many got
through and that is a five-time increase
over the last five years combined or
two-time increase over the last five
years combined a number of people seized
at the border so the bad guys looking at
the southern border seeing how poorest
it is seeing how lacks our standards are
and they are exploiting it to get into
this country we've seen a plot against
president uh former president bush to
kill him with the legal aliens on the
border we saw a plot by two illegal
aliens to uh convict can constitute a
mass casualty event on july 4th so this
is real and what they're doing is
creating a ticking time bomb that it's
gonna have long-term implications far
past the hundred eight thousand people
who died this year of a drug overdose no
you know you're quite right about that
what i guess i find far more startling
this week is that gate video more than
anything else i i get the busing that's
big i don't want to minimize it and uh
and sharing sort of the the problems
here that the texas governors had but
that gate issue on private property in
the federal government deciding to open
what obviously the private owner wanted
clothes and the texas national guardsmen
wanted closed
that's a big deal because that seems to
be telegraphic to migrants and
those with far more you know evil
intentions uh that these are the entry
points and if you can get there
you're safe here
you're most certainly right in the
coyotes someone's doing working for the
cartels across these people they know
where the pressure points are and know
where the easy points are every place
now was getting easy to come across and
just so you know the process those
people came across they got through that
gate they were processed they were sent
to what's called non-government
organizations right that get millions
and billions from the us those ngos then
put them all over the country and we
can't get information from the ngos as
to where they're going because they're
private entities it's like a money
laundering operation for god's sakes
that's what's really hard it's hard for
us to conduct oversight because they
they don't they're not telling us where
they're sending them
it's just amazing congressman thank you
very very much we always reach out to
the administration on this or anyone
homeland security to update us on this
we never hear back but we keep trying
because we have phones that work
we can we can make the call and then
it's up to them to return the call
oftentimes
actually
all the time they don't but but this is
a big issue it's not a left or right
issue not a conservative liberal issue
it's a very big issue